hola hello we're traveling through
Germany and stopping off in a few major
cities today we're in Hamburg a great
port city which was part of the
Hanseatic League let's explore this
great city lovely being at the Town Hall
over there and they're still Michael's
Church
oh that's pretty it symbolizes the
mercantile cities of the Hanseatic
League
look at the lovely arcades over there
how beautiful very interesting people
must have been very small back then to
get up these narrow stairs window gives
you an idea of how the widow's used to
talk and gossip with each other once
these buildings seem like doll houses do
Binaca
oh yeah it's really big its Germany's
largest port
this boat trip is very important to us
we can see all the city of Hamburg and
the port very interesting
that's the elephant honey the concert
halls a number of problems have delayed
its completion we have problems like
that in Brazil our country
Wow hopefully mental wow it's narrow
and it's cold I'm freezing
they toss this tunnel feels old you feel
like you're in an earlier century it's
really interesting
what's special about that tunnel is the
marvelous view at the end and with that
we say goodbye to Hamburg